ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales soy
herminia fernández por andrés espinal
ocho periodistas y foto reporteros han
fallecido desde el comienzo de la
invasión rusia de ucrania en febrero
pasado en jarque una de las ciudades en
el frente de la guerra los cronistas se
están acostumbrando a informar sobre la
muerte a pesar de no haber estado
preparados para hacerlo nuestras
enviadas especiales irene sabios y
leticia álvarez hablaron con dos
periodistas de esta ciudad para entender
cómo el conflicto ha cambiado su
profesión
con apenas tres años de experiencia ana
periodista del medio digital nac y pelo
no se imaginó que se convertiría en una
reportera de guerra y que además sería
una de las dos periodistas de su diario
que no abandonaron su ciudad durante el
conflicto
la mayoría de la gente de mi redacción
oyó al principio de la guerra para poner
a salvo a sus familias donde was
visibles y colegas lejos anna lleva
meses durmiendo y trabajando en este
sótano donde ahora está ubicada la
redacción mantener la serenidad para
seguir informando es un gran reto es
prótesis flash de hecho chan trabajo
cuando bates oye
lo más difícil es mantener bajo control
la ansiedad y controlar las emociones
para trabajar contando las historias de
los que sufren los esteroides y que es
estable
colega colega de anna dejó su trabajo
como fotógrafo de eventos comerciales
para dedicarse a la crónica de guerra
dice que quiere mostrar al mundo lo que
está ocurriendo en su país y se prepara
para lo peor con cursos de primeros
auxilios
si me siento a salvo mi papá ha estado
luchando desde el comienzo de la guerra
noches personas droguett en viene
se siente y la sal
reporteros sin fronteras ha documentado
la muerte de ocho periodistas del
comienzo del conflicto en ucrania una
cifra que ucrania eleva hasta los
treinta incluyendo aquellos reporteros
que se afiliaron para combatir usaban
instructores de experiencia de
conflictos explica que muchos
periodistas fallecen porque no saben qué
hacer o se trata de casos desesperados
como las estadísticas dicen que la
mayoría de los fallecimientos se
producen por hemorragias masivas no
controladas
o le guían a no tienen intención de
dejar de momento a la ciudad son jóvenes
reporteros que quieren crecer y hacer
carrera en el trabajo de campo más duro
la guerra
muchas mujeres que estaban en edad
reproductiva antes de que se aprobara el
histórico caso de robert sus way en 1973
no se imaginan cómo será la vida tras la
derogación de este derecho en eeuu en
términos generales se espera que el
acceso al aborto se corta para 36
millones de mujeres y que la mitad de
los estados de eeuu introduzcan nuevas
restricciones o prohibiciones en el
siguiente informe conoceremos la
historia de karen muhlhauser una
activista de los derechos de la mujer
que se vio obligada a auto inducirse un
aborto en los años 60 aquí el reporte de
que te van core gestan y matthew más van
karen muhlhauser puede ver el techo del
tribunal supremo de eeuu desde las
ventanas de su apartamento en washington
dice
hace casi 60 años abortó sola y en
secreto
ahora con 80 años no se imaginan los
derechos de la mujer regresando a esos
días oscuros
estuve buscando fotos pero no pude
encontrar ninguna de cuando hice esa
tontería
una vez en college park en este foro
cuando estaba en la universidad allá en
1964 vivía con mi novio y quedé
embarazada un embarazo no planificado mi
auto indígeno aborto y es sorprendente
que estoy aquí en el scanner que me
dicen granier a estar gp en exceso al
frente y sin él
pensé que había tenido éxito con la auto
inducción y me estaba preparando para
subir a un autobús para volver a la
universidad pero me desmayé en el suelo
de la terminal de autobuses y me
desperté en la oficina con un charco de
sangre y creo que había cuatro o cinco
personas allí y debían saber lo que me
había pasado pero no me ofrecieron
ninguna ayuda me dejaron cambiarme de
ropa e irme
michaels
en life
no solo culpa el tribunal supremo de lo
que puede ocurrir con los derechos
reproductivos en eeuu también señala a
las generaciones más jóvenes
acz
me sorprende porque cuando cumplen 18
años pero los jóvenes de este país son
los que menos votan quizás el 20 por
ciento de los jóvenes con derecho a voto
votan a los chicos así que creo que
llegar a los jóvenes para los el aborto
ha sido legal toda su vida les resulta
difícil de imaginar porque la mayoría de
ellos apoyan el derecho a la muerte
monroe hauser ha sido un activista de
los derechos de la mujer durante casi
seis décadas y promete pasar el resto de
su vida luchando para defender esos
derechos fundamentales
el líbano es un país rico en recursos
hídricos tiene montañas nevadas que
alimentan a 15 ríos y más de 2.000
arroyos sin embargo años de la mala
gestión de este servicio sumado a la
profunda crisis económica que afronta el
país han provocado que hay una escasez
crítica de agua potable en la mayor
parte del país y telmo net nos trae la
historia
theresa prefiere pagar un poco más por
agua purificada certificada y no poner
en peligro la salud de su familia la
deficiencia del servicio en el líbano ha
convertido este recurso natural en un
bien al alcance de pocos
no deberíamos pagar por beber agua pero
nuestro gobierno nos ha puesto en esta
situación hay un nuevo brote de
hepatitis a el agua del grifo no se debe
usar ni para lavar las verduras a pesar
de que el líbano es un país con
abundantes recursos hídricos cuando el
agua de la montaña llega a los ríos se
contamina ya que también se vierten
residuos industriales y productos
químicos agrícolas tratar el agua para
hacerla limpia supone un desafío para
los biólogos que monta carros para
filmar que el agua del río litani llega
muy contaminada aquí bajamos mil puntos
del nivel de toxicidad pero si no hay
inspecciones en las fábricas para frenar
los vertidos se vuelve a contaminar la
sociedad esfuerzos cogen el real y tania
es un ejemplo de cómo la mala
administración de los suministros de
agua y la corrupción endémica han
convertido sus aguas en extremadamente
tóxicas como consecuencia más de 4
millones de personas la población más
vulnerable se enfrenta a una escasez
aguda
si no se toman medidas urgentes ha
advertido unicef la gran demanda de agua
potable ha hecho proliferar las empresas
de distribución pero no todas las
compañías están registradas y ponen en
riesgo la salud de los libaneses
hay empresas que la venden más barata
pero a veces no ha pasado el control de
calidad todo depende de la confianza
entre el consumidor y la compañía que le
suministra el agua por ejemplo el agua
potable ya no es asequible para poder
llenar los tanques de los edificios los
libaneses se dejan la mitad de su sueldo
pagando a empresas privadas para que no
se sequen los grifos de sus casas
nosotros llenar el tanque el camión nos
cuesta casi tanto como el agua que
vendemos el precio del combustible se ha
triplicado y tengo que pagar también a
los transportistas no de rentaron igual
que en barrios empobrecidos como a moria
mud donde muchas familias viven bajo el
umbral de la pobreza y no pueden pagar
el agua conseguir una ración para cada
miembro de la familia es una batalla
diaria
colombia votó por el primer gobierno de
izquierda y francia- márquez será la
primera vicepresidenta afrodescendiente
en la historia del país latinoamericano
aunque nuestra conocida por su
experiencia política tiene una gran
trayectoria como líderes a sus luchas
medioambientales la representación de
minorías como la indígena y la
afrodescendiente así como la de las
mujeres le ayudaron a conseguir votos un
equipo de france 24 estuvo en exclusiva
junto a francia márquez antes de las
elecciones
es francia márquez la primera
vicepresidenta afrodescendiente de
colombia
una llegada al poder cerca de los suyos
en campaña visito poblaciones que
defienden el medio ambiente
como esta de pan ce a los pies de la
cordillera de los andes donde la
comunidad defiende un río declarado
sujeto de derechos por la justicia mi
récord este es la ilusión
de qué hablas barba y cambiar críticos
le achacan falta de experiencia acaba de
irrumpir en política pero su liderazgo
social y ambiental se remonta a sus
trece años cuando inició una lucha
contra la minería en 2018 fue reconocida
con el premio goldman el premio nobel
del medio ambiente
por su lucha 'francia márquez ha
recibido amenazas desde hace años cuenta
con esquema de seguridad para muchos
colombianos es la forma de hacer
política
[Aplausos]
a cali tercera ciudad del país llegó
desplazada por el conflicto
[Aplausos]
fue trabajadora de la limpieza y se
convirtió en abogada en el pacífico
colombiano en segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales junto con el
presidente gustavo petro lograron siete
de cada diez votos es donde hay una
mayor concentración de población
afrodescendiente que nunca dejaba
gobernar una persona
también ha recibido un gran apoyo
femenino laura madre cantautora
feminista piensa que la vicepresidencia
es el paso previo a la presidencia yo
creo que ella lo que está haciendo es
ganar espacio y abrir espacio para que
muchas más personas como ellas tengan
acceso al poder es entre los afros los
indígenas y las mujeres donde más apoyo
ha encontrado francia márquez 2 nadie a
los que quiere representar desde la
vicepresidencia
gracias por acompañarnos en
corresponsales sigan con la programación
de france 24 y france 24 puntocom